how does a blind girl chop an onion how
does a blind girl
light a candle how do blind people dream
how do blind people read and write we
use braille and braille is a system of
raised dots that i can feel with my
fingers
and that's how i read i write braille by
using this
it's called a perkins brailler it
punctures holes into paper for me
this is a braille computer and i know it
as a braille note
it has a braille keyboard on here and a
refreshable
braille display one braille cell
represents
one character and is comprised of six
dots
so for instance if i wanted to write the
alphabet for letter a
just dot one would be raised for letter
b
dot one and two and for c one and four
how does a blind girl pick up her guide
dog's poopy
and then i've got double bag double poop
bags
and then when she moves i feel i go up
and pick up the poop
i feel the grass to where her poop is
very glamorous
can't believe i'm doing this on tiktok
and there we go
how does a blind girl chop an onion
chips
always use their fingers anyway to guide
a knife and they don't necessarily look
at the chopping board when they're
chopping and it's just the same for me
i use a serrated knife and it's very
very sharp
so i'm not going to hurt myself chop the
sides of the onion off it's route
chop a line down so then i can
peel off the layers because all onions
have layers
i chop in half
like that if the onions are flat against
the chopping board and i go with the
grain
bridging my hands
[Music]
how does a blind girl deal with a gas
heart while she's cooking an
egg pan in one hand i'm gonna feel along
the cooker while
it's cold and off i'm gonna place it in
the center
where the flame would be and it's
getting centralized have a good feel
this is a water boiler it rattles when
the water in the pan is brought up to
the boil i'm going to place it in the
bottom with the heat still off
a freshly boiled kettle i'm just going
to fill up the pan
[Music]
it's boiling yay i can hear it i've
lowered the heat it's now simmering and
it's
calmed down i'm gonna lower the eggs
into the water in the chip basket
how does a blind girl light a candle
i've got some extra long matches so when
the match
is lit the flame is going to be as far
away from my fingers
as humanly possible also matchboxes
the side of them are so tactile so i'm
going to strike
the match away from me
woodwick candles are the best because
they have an extra long
wick so this blind girl can feel with
her one hand
and bring the match to feel
with the other
[Music]
and this candle sounds like the fire is
on
when it's burning so audibly it's
amazing i always like candles on glass
tables
just in case anything happens nothing
will ever set on fire
how does a blind girl have a shower this
is my shampoo and my conditioner but as
you can see
both bottles feel and probably look
exactly the same and this is to be
honest the case
with most brands in the supermarkets i
just do
the hair bubble trick where i just wrap
around the hair bubble onto the
conditioner
and there we go i know the difference
between both of them
but also i'm very organized on my shower
shelves
as you can see i have two shelves on the
top is my shower gels
and on the bottom to the left is my
shampoo to the right is my conditioner
i never mix these up otherwise i will be
putting conditioner on first and shower
gel on my hair
how does a blind girl turn a shower on
though it's very tactile i just turn the
knobs
and i know what temperature to have on
and left is the on
[Music]
as a blind woman i use these tactile
markings to navigate
you have probably seen them all over
british streets
but what do they mean equally space dots
in a grid formation
mean you're coming up to a dropped curve
if you see this type of paving and it's
red like this one you're coming up to a
crossing with lights
but if it's yellow you're just coming up
to a regular dropped curb
diagonal dots mean you're near a train
station platform or
there's going to be a big drop
horizontal stripes along the path mean
you're coming up to some
steps this lot in shape paving means
you're coming up to a street level
hazard
or a tram horizontal and vertical
stripes next to each other indicate
there is a bike path
next to a footpath and sometimes you
will occasionally see one
tactile line to and from a destination
this one is from
old street tube station to moorfields
eye hospital
i'm blind so how do i type this is my
iphone keyboard and i swipe
left and right to hear the letters and
i'm going to double tap
to type it and then i'm going to find i
i double tap hey and on a laptop i touch
type
i've learnt my way around the keyboard
usually
f and j also have tactile bumps on the
keys
as well i'm blind and this is how i
differentiate banknotes
in my purse this is money reader a
fantastic
app that i use to tell banknotes apart
i'm just gonna hover over
each note there's two on the table and
we'll see what they are
this is the first one five pounds
love it and
antenna also on 10 and 20 pound notes
you can feel
raised tactile bumps similar to braille
and that's how
i sometimes without the app open i tell
that this is a ten pound note
how they're does
she has bells on so i can hear her how
does a blind person
cross the road i use the tactile marking
to find the property
i've navigated to the box and i can feel
the button click it
it's very tactile i can't see the wait
sign so i here for the audible signals
but if there isn't any audible signals
on a crossing which
sometimes happens sometimes doesn't i
feel for underneath
and there's a spinning cone
how do blind people dream not all blind
people dream the same at all
and for me as a completely blind person
for eight years
and i was completely cited for 17
i dream as if i'm in a storybook i'm
reading the words on a page
i'm listening to the sounds i'm tasting
things if i'm in a restaurant
this imaginary restaurant um i'm you
know
touching things i don't have visual
memories anymore so
it's just like that in my dreams i do
have way more nightmares now though
[Music]
how does a blind person film and post a
tick tock video
so when i'm filming tic tocs inside and
it's just a chatty one where i'm sitting
on the sofa
i personally love to be quite
independent with that first of all olly
here my sighted fiance he's lovely he
sets up the tripod for me and gets me in
frame
and then i can use voiceover on my
iphone to click start and stop on the
recording
when i'm filming a tiktok video where
i'm moving around a lot more or doing
something or i'm outside
olly helps me because i couldn't
possibly keep track of the camera if i'm
moving about
so this is when i hand it over to ollie
to edit i turn voiceover off
and then he saves it in drafts for me
thank you sweetheart thank you very much
hashtag blind
and then i click post here are some
myths about blindness that you should
stop believing
when interacting with a blind person you
shouldn't say
look at that or have you seen this never
ever change your vocabulary when talking
to a blind person like me
i personally always say did you watch
that great tv show
i can't technically watch it but i
listen with audio description
and i'm not going to change my vocab
when talking to a blind person you need
to speak really loudly otherwise we
won't know you're talking to us
no just have a chat with me as you would
any other person
my eyes are the only things that don't
work blind people have
superior hearing hearing is my main
sense but it's not better than a sighted
person's i have learned to hone
in on the sounds around me a lot more
and obviously because i've adapted to
that way of life it's the way
i personally see the world how not to
sight guide a blind person
hi i'm billy i'm your passenger
assistant come with me
[Music]
hi i'm george i'm your passenger
assistant i'm glad to help you today
george how are you thank you let's go
this is the correct way to sight guide a
blind person
hi i'm billy from passenger assistant
would you like an elbow
oh hi lily yes please thank you so much
let's go
[Music]
what do you do if you see a blind person
out and about and they look lost
what i would say is a lot of the time
we're not lost because
we have a lot of accessible apps on our
iphone
like google maps or blind square or
microsoft soundscape
they're brilliant for navigation as a
blind woman
also we have usually had orientation and
mobility sessions with a qualified
mobility instructor
and they have taught us how to use a
cane or a guide dog
so on the off chance that we do look
lost which is quite possible
the motto should be just ask don't grab
so for instance if i'm in a train
station maybe your name is sally
and you're a passerby i would love for
you to introduce who you are so i'm
sally
i'm a passerby would you like assistance
and i can say yes or no
[Music]
you